let's go next to how about uh oh no I
don't want to go to this person I'm
getting a notification that their audio
is just a disaster let's go to uh
Guillaume from beautiful Montreal I I
understand you got snow last night
Guillaume
uh yes can you hear me right I can hear
you fine
perfect and I'm not gonna say it tonight
because it's still coming on
ah it's still snowing uh yep pretty
pretty big one I'm probably gonna have
to shovel somewhere tonight too
beautiful
uh so how's the weather on your side the
weather's good uh no snow here but uh
you know uh I I don't remember when we
last spoke I am considering making my
next return to Montreal very very soon
as I have friends and family there and
it's been a while since I've been there
in winter last time I was there in
January my nose would instantly freeze
when I would step out into the street to
give a recommendation as to when maybe
closer to mid to end February well oh I
see that's that's already better
uh the the weather at that point is
usually not less cold but less
aggressive okay
all right I'll try to make that happen
but this isn't about me what's on your
mind today
so the last couple times we talked um I
threw hypotheticals out there but
I it was mostly me trying to uh
formulate the best way I could and then
I decided to just wait after the midterm
speed so let's do not get accused of
trying to influence anything
uh but there was a question that came up
I was on Twitter a lot recently I know
my bad that's on me I guess uh and a lot
of the conversations uh ended up uh
moving towards people
attacking
the moderation of Twitter yeah working
along with the US government which I've
not entirely sure they were that active
with they might have been in
communication I don't know
uh for censorship when most of what we
could see was essentially
the the the uh not entirely sure what
agency would have worked with Twitter
that front but it was trying to reduce
the impact of Russian misinformation on
influencing the midterms yeah
the question was well the problem was
the persons to whom I was talking to all
all about we should allow Russian
misinformation to affect the U.S
elections and whatnot and that brought
to me the major question of with the U.S
trying to push their nose until
literally every other country's economy
and uh government system and everything
maybe without necessarily trying to give
them a a vote or any actual power
why don't we
um trying to phrase it why don't you
guys more regularly consider what other
countries think about candidates
in terms of trouble but these there's
two different things here so there's
actually three different things here at
Guillaume so the first one is is there
not a hypocrisy in that the U.S has
interests in leaders around the world
and works to influence the way elections
go
occasionally or sometimes and yeah it
says it's wrong when other countries try
to do it to the U.S yes that is a double
standard but every country does that
every country wants to have a say about
their own leaders and to have a say
about everyone else's leaders so it's a
hypocrisy that is not unique to the
United States however the United States
has the resources to maybe better affect
what happens in other countries more so
than other countries that's number one
about it at times
sorry what was that Gail
I said some at times they can get really
aggressive about it I mean we're not
absolutely absolutely so there's one
thing it is a double standard okay yep
second part of it
shouldn't Americans care more what the
world thinks about the leaders we pick
my opinion is that the answer is yes now
that doesn't mean that people around the
world should get votes that's not what
I'm saying but for example when I think
about when George W Bush was president
and the world was essentially against
the invasion of Iraq and Republicans
here said that doesn't matter we do
what's best for us I think it would be
smarter and more sophisticated to say
well
it would be good to know why the world
is against this Invasion even though
ultimately we do what we do let's
actually think about that and similarly
when World opinion of trump was very low
and World opinion of Biden is higher
I don't say oh those are [ __ ] Europeans
who cares I say that's interesting I
want to know more about why because it's
important to me what the world thinks
about what we're doing here so to answer
that question the answer is absolutely
yes but these are sort of a couple
different things you're asking about
I guess
um there's the fact that I was not
entirely sure how to bring it up well
you did beautifully yeah you really did
I mean there's the whole uh there's the
whole aspect uh according to the people
I was talking to Russian misinformation
is all good all Gucci everything should
be accepted and seen as fact but oh you
then communist Canadians over there you
go there I mean
as it specifically applies to your
friend I I don't I don't find your
friend to be particularly you know
sophisticated in their thinking but but
I hope I've at least outlined a few of a
few of my thoughts I've got to run okay
I appreciate you calling
have a great day all right there we go
always good to hear from Guillaume from
Montreal